hi I'm Greg and I'm John I'm Frankie has
everything she did so much sexier than
what we did because we both look that
was a show here cause the woods I
thought no I'm working on trying
I don't know how glad we're trying
listen guys um what makes money you guys
too
a week ago I said her watched these
videos from the Filipino company
jollibee room that had these Valentine's
Day commercials have you heard me
ah I've heard a Joey deal another
commercial there do you reacting to them
through the waters like the most
emotionally provoking commercial crying
like right like that you're shocked yeah
one of them eyeball didn't operate like
anyway this is not a jolly commercial
but a lot of Filipino people have been
subscribing mainly because I'm so
looking at you you know and they like
that oh well done whatever you cook it
around good Julie talking and your
agents that gotta counter this let's go
down to white guy you know you need your
token white guy yeah yeah you know every
Asian Grimm help me get around 10 so
back in December there is some video
that some of the Philippines called
create courage robe wanna stall hashtag
craker I feel like I'm gonna cry
you might see John cry let's pause
insensitive well I've gotten working
through this is under like I buy
something I used to be like you know
movies made me cry and I order you get
your like watch repeat episodes of
friends and I still cry crying when
you're alone like watching a movie the
best like The Green Mile why I focal
wise metalworkers alright let's watch
what the Filipinos have to offer
oh god you gonna cook this man
ah don't do persone before sons okay
cute
[Music]
starwars yeah
[Music]
oh cool
[Music]
people are mad at stormtrooper
[Music]
commercial for Oh watch nothing off the
helmet man how the stormtroopers came to
be they're all Filipino Museum
[Music]
yeah
if it all
what happens this is unlike laughing and
I found out I was not expecting that at
the end was when the clips came in I
really thought that it was going to be a
commercial for just robot dude I'm so
much better than that my everything shot
ok that's what I mean by Filipino
commercial like they're the other ones I
thought were significantly more
emotional but they still have this diss
appeal where it's like oh is it my sis
is joyful and here's something
heartbreaking yet you could possibly be
I thought they were making a joke about
like now I think that you know that joy
strippers originated from the
Philippines they're born this way I
guess first I was like is this just like
these kids is gonna grow up to be a star
something like maybe I'm like a
birthmark on his face and you or she is
like not proud of you know like it can
be mean to each other yeah so maybe to
hide that I was so much more than I
thought it's gonna be like John Rogen's
face that's why he was ashamed over here
to hell I wanted to come to come he will
ring the bell
yeah I know you were going to add he's
gonna call ahead of time really can you
have a table to the side listen now I
know she's not note no less than 400
thread count machine so a great building
y'all have to share this chair together
and in the film yeah why a whole suit it
needs to be 67 degrees but do you see
how these commercials are also shot so
wonderfully doing they all tell a story
you're not just like usually quickly
like the only probably felt like an ad
was with a Julia Bush at Star Wars for
like 15 seconds other than that so it's
like a complete short film that this kid
who loves Star Wars and escaped and was
disbanded in valoran and the classmates
came together yeah I'll wear the helmet
I don't know what care what condition
machine some type of breathing condition
always be with you
melissa was sad maybe a colorful set oh
maybe the only courage disturb your zina
so we're not idea I'm not writing your
letter no no one no one knows
it's supposed to be meant for
interpretation it's an abstraction just
bet this is what did excited I think the
point is like she's got other all
showing support some kind of things a
little more Gary run indicate yelling oh
yeah she's hiding the oxygen mask and
then there are the kids like Manny like
she's showing together like show their
support like hey you don't gotta feel so
low like we're not gonna add we're
weirdo you know like when we when
everyone might shave their head for like
cancer so yeah I wanna do something like
this I wanna wear John wrote the math
man telling Matt I just loved it with it
this plays out because you're not
expecting that to happen when they take
off the map women when teaching swimming
banette accent Alex but Alex was immune
effect me I thought it was a boy this
whole oh my I did want you to say hi
probably Wars whatever sickness doesn't
matter if you're a boy or girl if you
think it's a girl and I think she's got
short hair because if she's going out of
chemo yeah her hair wait they only
showed the nametag with the name Alex if
so it was for the audience to not know
whether it's a boy or girl and then at
the end it doesn't matter because yeah
oh yeah the Holzer cares does not care
for the first part of this that
character it just gets to be a you had
up your breath is just a little storm
trooper it could be down black and
that's start what you think is for such
like it could be a no Anna deaths are
Bush yeah like part of the part of the
jam is like it could be anybody and
that's what's interesting to me is like
I've never seen an ad for a movie like
this where it's like drawing a distinct
connection between like this movie but
also like you know something good that
is doing for somebody's life and I'm
like that that's I think that's cool
that's the kind of big enough like I'm
sure if we played it back we'd see even
more actually yeah that's like the best
stuff that comes out of fandom like
loving movies and like having a culture
around that is like people getting
together and using the ideas for good
stuff totally but one thing I thought
was interesting with like how
brother was just bonding with her the
whole time yeah and at first it was kind
of cute the brothers is Bonnie but then
you see like oh this is just a brother
being like super [ __ ] supportive or
while your sibling is going through this
right now
yeah it's really about love and care and
and then I did at the end you're
thinking is gonna be some like
stormtroopers Star Wars punchline is
something run like oh no Kirk oh that's
great
I got to start watching Filipino movies
I think I feel like whoever makes these
to just come over here you know the
commercials are moving me I only wonder
how their movies and shows are yeah time
for some recommendations you Filipino
well the thing is to like now I want to
know what a regular days worth of
Filipino commercials looks like because
like our yeah never watch TV I wouldn't
I would need to like one every other
you're watching family guy isn't crying
in between don't even drama is the two
minutes is four minutes of commercials
you're about what everyone is going to
punch you in the heart
this one's got me in the gut because
other funny versions of these were
they're just like really hilarious in a
very relate I have no idea
this video has over a all mm dislikes
yeah but 17,000 mics you know who
dislike video like that
come on Trump supporter to help well can
i for to remove it the first person a
requested this couple of comments came
in with the first one
Francisco kilo kilo okay Wow kilo kilo
kilo kilo isn't my like the type of
cocaine that's just anything like how
you measure this is to unit especially
honey quick measure measure coke I guess
into in kilos I know that
do you well thank you to everyone who
watched this video including the awesome
Filipinos who have been subscribing the
Hanul really my brothers and sisters and
future lovers if I ever troubled it
because that's what's happening yeah
I'm sleeping with whatever gender I can
get when I'm out there when you go to
the Philippines because now I go so a
guy that's next to Hawaii right describe
to the real range X John is real this is
Jerry on Twitter and the insta of the
gramming and he is the social manager of
media on the Blum House of the real
rejects yay Wendy Lee is on the movie
couple channels where something insert
joke about being a couple I've done the
other millions s where she is in love
with Dustin Hoffman adorable she's a
little bit older than her but okay he
likes his Asian hello darkness my old
friends this is crazy it was playing his
movie and Jesus uncle at her videos yeah
water so shout out to uh Dennis tang
he never says hi to me yeah I didn't
though I try to but I can't actually
like he doesn't want me to that's how I
felt when I first met but I'm just like
Dennis you're Asian you can't tell the I
am half asian I feel like we have a
commonality here let's talk if you just
think I Thank You Dennis and you'll see
he does have a way to make you in there
he's really nice either a work mode or
I'm sure when you're like out having
drinks he like super fun nobody no one's
no one sees accrete you just work open
so he is like one of the funniest people
I know right now is on a scary